making his sixth start of this season
and here's the o2 by frankie and that's
taking on the outside corner ring him up
strike three caught perfect pitch
the blue jays are going to send four
lefties to the mound to start these four
games beginning tonight with steven matz
two-two grounded to third panic to
second one simeon to first in time
strike three call right on the corner
here's the announcement of marcus simeon
many of these fans are standing
great to see and so well deserved and
now marcus steps out
tips his hat
class move by sean murphy too behind the
plate ray to stand up and actually back
off the plate and bill miller the umpire
did the same thing
so marcus is
the blue jays first base runner
uh the swelling went down very quickly
and he was able to text bob melvin the
manager yesterday and say i'm okay put
me in the lineup and he responded
matt strikes him out on a pitch up in
the zone and he battles back from 3-0 to
get olson one down
[Applause]
that's fair pass panic down the third
base
line chapman will
have a stand-up double with one out here
in the second inning so third double of
the year for chapman
and here's lowry
[Applause]
right feeling hit well because going
back beazio near the wall beagle leaps
off the wall
chapman's gonna round third he's gonna
score lowry has an rbi double and the
a's grab a one-nothing lead and here's
biscotti so back-to-back one-out doubles
gives the a's an early lead
in the ear to left and it's hit pretty
well hernandez going back turning around
and that baby's
it's now three-nothing athletics in the
second we talked about you see where
they want the pitch
asking for it down
just a slider finds its way right into
the middle of the zone piscotty out on
his front foot but that does not prevent
him from packing his bags
[Applause]
next stop
pound town
2-0 and a liner into left field that'll
get down for a base hit
up to second on the play goes jansen so
a couple of men on for bo buchet struck
out on three pitches against montas in
the first and he grounds one up the
middle and through a base hit
jensen around third he is getting the
wave the throw is cut and it'll be an
rbi single for buchet to get the blue
jays on the board
up to second on the play was biggio
three to one as guerrero lines the ball
into right a base hit
putting the brakes on at third is bishop
that ball was hit awfully hard into
right field a line drive single for
vladi and the bases are loaded with one
out three to one for the a's and now
let's see if tay oscar hernandez can
keep the line moving here biggio bechet
and guerrero aboard
and the first pitch to tayasaka a
swinging a ball line into left field a
base hit
bizio into score the shed is on his way
home guerrero slides into third
hernandez is it second and this game is
tied
jansen sliding even further inside but
the ball is left out over the plate
bisho going back and he'll have to play
it off the wall
he bare hands it back into the infield
and they get piscotty at second
what a play by kevin biggio he gives up
on it early knowing he's not going to
catch it and then plants that right foot
catches the roll with his bare hand
and throws him out
surprised that piscotty is running with
the knee that he just fouled the ball
off of his knee
and the play is right in front of him
2-2 on the way and that's a good
change-up right there weak contact
jansen and the throw hits andrews in the
back
now the question is as the run came in
to score
where was andrews and they're going to
call him out and bob melvin's coming out
to argue but andrews was out of the
running lane
he was to the left of the line so he was
in fair territory and the ruling on the
field
is that he
impeded jansen's ability to make a throw
and you can see he wasn't out there by
much but he was out of the running lane
and immediately he was called out
[Applause]
kemp at second orianna with an rbi
opportunity
[Applause]
high in the air to left field hernandez
back and
that baby's gone
and lauriano has homered in back-to-back
games
and the athletics take a 5-3
[Applause]
and just a little change piece didn't
quite turn all the way over
you can see the laser pose them up
for the third day in a row
pack
he's got a base hit to left field
so marcus is on base for the second time
a one out single
the blue jays threatening in the eighth
inning and marcus simeon is up the
former oakland a
two and another one and this one will
get to the back stop guerrero will come
into score easily
grichik up to second on the wild pitch
and the blue jays are back within a run
[Applause]
fast runner at second base
struck him out
second strikeout for trevino here in the
eighth inning
and a slider struck him out and the a's
take game one of this four game series
so mount us gets his third win diekman
gets his third save the a's get their
18th win of the year